certainly looks like the Russians were
behind it something that should never
ever happen and we're taking it very
seriously
it is absolutely atrocious prowess and
outrageous what Russia did in Salisbury
we have responded to that frankly Russia
should go away it should shut up it is
time to impose serious political and
economic consequences on Moscow United
States is working together with our
allies and partners to ensure that this
kind of a pourraient attack does not
happen again we are ready to return into
partnership with the European Union when
our European neighbors lose interest in
following American Russia phobic
tendencies trouble ministration making
big steps today sanctioning 19 people
five Russian organizations 13 of them
were indicted by Bob Muller in his
investigation just a few weeks ago what
about this and also the Russia
investigation latest let's bring in our
panel Jonathan Swan national political
reporter for Axios Molly Hemingway
senior editor at The Federalist and
Olivier Knox Yahoo News chief Washington
correspondent Molly critics of the
administration say because 13 of the 19
who were sanctioned by the
administration today were from the
Muller investigation that the
administration is essentially saying
that the Muller investigation is a-ok
well there are parts of the Malheur
investigation that I think nobody has a
problem with the whole idea behind
investigation is to look into meddling
in the u.s. election those 13
indictments had everything to do with
meddling in the US election I think
where people are concerned is when
Moeller goes far afield from the
election and far afield from sort of the
narrow confines that people understand
as being a good thing to investigate but
if people meddled then they should be
then they should be held accountable and
not just by charging them with a crime
that nobody will ever see them take
responsibility for it but sanctions are
something more like that it seems like
is this the new administration take on
Russia Jonathan on stepping up what
nikki Haley said at the UN what we're
seeing today and the
the revelation of the cyberattacks on
u.s. infrastructure including the
electrical grid yeah I mean Trump's
instincts have always been very strongly
on Russia which is that they are the key
to solving the Middle East problem a
good relationship with Russia but
evidence upon evidence upon evidence has
I think now maybe not totally change his
mind but at least moved him away from
where he was maybe six months ago and
certainly the team around him a fairly
hawkish particularly nikki Haley here's
Sarah Sanders today on friend or foe
from Putin that's something that Russia
is gonna have to make that determination
they're gonna have to decide whether or
not they want to be a good actor or a
bad actor I think you can see from the
actions that we've taken up until this
point we're gonna be tough on Russia
until they decide to change their
behavior yeah so the sections they
announced today are are notable but
they're not huge a lot of the people who
were were announced today we're already
under American sanctions both under
Obama and an earlier wave of Trump
sanctions what's really notable is the
letter that accompanied the sanctions
that basically lays the election
meddling at Vladimir Putin's doorstep it
says that the GRU the main military
intelligence service was directly
involved in a meddling that's really
important the decision to reveal this
previously undisclosed infrastructure
attack that's gonna get a lot of
well-deserved headlines it's very
worrisome they apparently had the
ability at one point to turn things on
and off and that's a that's a
significant thing and then the
attribution and punishment for the not
Pecha malware that raced through Europe
and did tens of billions of dollars in
damage you're definitely seeing a
rhetorical escalation from the
administration from administration we
have yet to see really the same
escalation in the rhetoric from the
president in the meantime New York Times
has a piece today about the Muller
investigation saying that Muller
subpoenaed the Trump Organization
demanding documents in the subpoena
delivered in recent weeks mr. Muller
ordered the Trump Organization to hand
over all records related to Russia and
other topics he's investigating Trump
Organization has said that it never had
real estate holdings in Russia but
witnesses recently interviewed mr.
Muller by mr. Muller have been asked
about a possible real estate deal in
Moscow the Trump Organization meantime
Molly is saying that they've been
cooperating
and that they've fully been handing over
documents so why a subpoena if that's
true well I'm being cooperation can go
along with a subpoena they might the
investigation might want to be very
particular about what they're looking
for and make sure that they get
everything not just having it be a
shared agreement but again there's a
political question in play here that we
have been spending a lot of time talking
investigating collusion with Russia
whether the Trump Organization colluded
with Russia to steal an election I'm not
sure if there's still a political
appetite to just look for a crime until
you find one I mean that's not that's
how you do things in Russia maybe it's
not how you do things in America where
you decide guilt and then you just keep
fishing fishing fishing until you can
find something to string someone up on
the same time you heard earlier in the
interviews senators Grassley and Graham
calling for another special counsel yeah
and I don't know the chances of that
happening but I think the most
significant thing about this story is
the story itself and how the president
of the United States will react to it
because yes maybe perhaps this
cooperation has been going on quietly
but we know that when the president sees
these stories on television I mean if
you were going to write a story to get
under his skin you would write that
story that they are mauler is delving
into the Trump Organization Trump said
on the record to the New York Times that
that would be a red line going into his
business dealings so I think that the
most interesting thing is the alchemy
that that creates there's also the issue
that this investigation began again to
look into collusion and what it what it
found pretty quickly is not collusion we
have all these congressional
investigations looking into it they
don't find collusion but what they do
find I don't think we know that with
them all up if anyone has information on
collusion it would be great to finally
get it out but what you did find out
really pretty quickly was that there
were problems at the FBI and Department
of Justice we knew it because there were
criminal leaks at the very beginning but
there have been all sorts of other
things that came out FISA abuses and
other problems we cannot expect the FBI
and Department of Justice to investigate
themselves and whether or not media
people actually care about this scandal
of a century or not we do need the
American people need answers for the
problems that are at the FBI and
Department of Justice so I would say
unlike what you're saying that there
that it's unlikely there will be a
special counsel I don't see how else you
restore the credibility of these
agencies unless you have someone truly
independent who can do the work in
to get and hold people accountable I
want to turn quickly to what the
president said that the that there's not
going to be or that the the stories of a
big shake-up in his White House are
overridden over exaggerated fake news
whatever you want to call it clearly
he's looking at making other moves we
just don't know when or how big yeah
last fall the president flatly denied
called it fake news when there were
reports that he was working on a plan to
replace Secretary of State Rex Tolson
with CIA director Mike Pompeo which is
exactly what has happened here now it is
true that sometimes the president will
reach out to advisors outside the White
House and tell them what do you think of
so-and-so should I replace so-and-so
with this other person and that
translates into the a lot of these
stories that are the president is
considering dumping the following people
now I'm told later McMaster has been
looking carefully at the possibility of
an exit but we've had enough casts to
this point that there's no reason to
think there's not more coming I mean it
you buy that so the White House is not
if you bret baier go to the White House
now and you say I have reporting that HR
McMaster was on its way out you will not
get a lot of pushback they're not going
to lean into pushing back on that that's
where we're at now there is a common
acceptance within the White House that
at some point probably in the fairly
near future he's gone but nobody as of
two hours ago within the presence in a
circle knew when that was going to
happen and who's gonna replace him so I
still haven't written the HR McMaster
story is gone because at this point it's
been written every week for eight months
at some point it will be correct I
believe it will be correct probably
fairly soon but as Olivier pointed out
when the president talks like this quite
openly it doesn't necessarily mean that
he's going to act imminently the parlor
games of Washington